The more ads you show, the
more money you can earn.
With AdMob Mediation, you
can maximize the number
of ads shown in your app,
pulling from multiple networks
to increase your fill rate.
Simply put, AdMob Mediation lets
you better manage your ad sales
and earn more money
from your inventory.
The best part-- it's completely
free to all of our developers.
Mediation lets you
serve ads to your apps
from multiple sources,
including the AdMob
network, third-party ad
networks, programmatic buyers,
demand-side platforms,
house ad campaigns, and even
direct-sold buyers.
We maximize your fill rate
and increase your monetization
by sending ad requests
to multiple networks
to ensure you find the best
available network to serve ads.
And because Google operates
the largest ad exchange
in the world, all of those
buyers and advertisers
are plugged in
directly to AdMob,
giving you access to an
unprecedented level of demand.
Mediation is
essentially a waterfall.
You configure which
networks you want
called in a particular order,
and the Mediation stack
will request ads from
those network sources
in that particular order.
The order of the waterfall can
be set by each ad network CPM.
The CPM of the
network is typically
based on the network's
historical performance
and is set manually.
That's why it's extremely
important to check your network
CPMs on a consistent
basis to ensure you
are maximizing your revenue.
To put it bluntly, if you aren't
updating your CPMs regularly,
you may be leaving
money on the table.
Because we know you need to
focus on building a great app
experience first and updating
CPMs can be extremely time
consuming, we created a feature
called Ad Network Optimization.
Ad Network Optimization
automatically
updates network CPMs
within your Mediation stack
and optimizes the order of those
networks based on the eCPM they
are giving you.
In other words, we
take the hard work
out of updating
your network CPMs,
ensuring you are serving the
highest paying ad for any given
impression every single time.
To ensure that AdMob is properly
competing within your Mediation
stack, we also created
the Optimized AdMob
Network feature.
In AdMob Mediation, you
could enable Google's demand
to bid alongside all
of your other networks
on a per-impression basis.
That means for every
ad request, if AdMob
is able to serve
an ad at a higher
CPM than the other
networks, it will.
When used together, Optimize
AdMob Network and Ad Network
Optimization are extremely
powerful in providing you
with the most revenue possible.
By ensuring that your
Mediation stack is dynamic,
we reduce the amount of
work you need in order
to keep your CPMs up to date,
while also driving the most
revenue for you.
Here's a quick summary
of the benefits
of using AdMob Mediation,
Ad Network Optimization,
and Optimize AdMob Network.
First, all of it's free.
There's absolutely no cost you
to use any of these features.
We will always serve
the highest paying ad,
even if it isn't from Google.
You'll have access to
Google's massive pool
of buyers, demand-side
platforms, programmatic buyers,
and much more.
You'll be able to manage
multiple networks, even
networks that we don't
officially support.
And finally, most
importantly, you'll
save time by allowing
you to focus on building
a great app for your users.
Thank you for watching.
Feel free to reach out
on Twitter and find us
on google.com/admob.
[MUSIC PLAYING]